well breakfast evening one day closer to
the Friday night deadline and top
Republicans received a critical
endorsement of this bipartisan
compromise from President Trump late
today after a discussion with Speaker
Paul Ryan and Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell president Trump signed off
press secretary Sarah Sanders saying the
president supported the bill because it
includes more funds to rebuild the
military such as the largest pay raise
for our troops in a decade more than 100
miles of new construction for the border
wall and other key domestic priorities
Congress didn't have time for a snow day
with the clock ticking to finish up a
1.3 trillion dollar spending package I'm
proud to announce it will meet a number
of vitally important objectives some of
the final pieces put the puzzle together
including two billion dollars in new
money for school safety measures a
bipartisan proposal tightening up
background checks for firearms purchases
and 1.6 billion dollars for the
president's border wall there's also 4.7
billion dollars to address the opioid
epidemic Republicans succeeded in
keeping Obamacare stabilization money
out of the deal and President Trump gets
a win on keeping the Gateway tunnel
project between New York and New Jersey
from being given priority status but
lawmakers were steamed about how the
deal went down Louisiana Senator John
Kennedy told Fox quote I think the whole
process sucks I think whoever designed
this isn't qualified to run a food truck
and he's not alone well it's 1.3
trillion dollars in spending
in the future because it's designed a
former House budget tear blasted the
Senate for creating a mess we passed a
budget here in this house
we passed appropriation bills it is the
Senate that cannot get their act
together and then we come to this place
where we do this huge spending bill that
has not been negotiated between the
House members and the Senate members
were just a small group of people top
Democrats signaled some relief that in
the final hours the impasse seems to
have broken I don't believe a good
neighbor shutdown I think if necessary
god forbid a continuing resolution but
I'd like to see it completed this week
there are some leadership types on both
sides hoping deadlines pressure and the
president's endorsement will help
produce a result but we've heard some
conservative frustration with the house
expected to vote tomorrow and lawmakers
won't have time to read the bill